>>> A HUGE HOSPITAL SYSTEM IN
NORTH CAROLINA THAT MADE THE
COVID VACCINE MANDATORY FOR ITS
EMPLOYEES SAYS 99% COMPLIED.
99%.
BUT ACCORDING TO THE "WASHINGTON
POST," 175 EMPLOYEES WHO REFUSED
TO GET VACCINATED HAVE BEEN
FIRED.
MEANWHILE, HERE IN NEW YORK,
GOVERNOR KATHY HOCHUL SIGNED AN
EXECUTIVE ORDER TO MITIGATE
POTENTIAL HELGT HEALTHCARE
WORKER SHORTAGES DUE TO THE
VACCINE MANDATE.
THE MAN DATE THAT WENT INTO
EFFECT TODAY REQUIRES ALL STATE
HEALTH CARE WORKERS TO BE
VACCINATED AGAINST COVID.
THE GOVERNOR'S ORDER
SIGNIFICANTLY EXPANDS THE
ELIGIBLE WORKFORCE AND ALLOWS
ADDITIONAL WORKERS TO ADMINISTER
COVID TESTING AND VACCINATIONS.
ACCORDING TO THE LATEST
INFORMATION FROM THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE, 92% OF HOSPITAL STAFF,
92% OF NURSING HOME STAFF, AND
89% OF ADULT HEALTHCARE FACILITY
STAFF HAD AT LEAST ONE VACCINE
DOSE.
A LOT OVER THE LAST FEW DAYS BUT
THAT STILL LEAVES THOUSANDS OF
HEALTHCARE WORKERS WHO ARE
REFUSING TO GET THE SHOT.
THE QUESTION IS WHY?
CNN'S MIGUEL MARQUEZ SAT DOWN
WITH TWO OF THEM TO FIND OUT.
>> AT SOME POINT, PUSH IS GOING
TO COME TO SHOVE AND THEY WILL
SAY YOU MUST BE VACCINATED OR
YOU WILL NOT HAVE A JOB.
>> I WILL NOT BE VACCINATED.
>> Reporter: HEALTHCARE WORKERS
DONNA SCHMIDT AND STEPHANIE ARE
REFUSING THE COVID-19 VACCINE NO
MATTER WHAT.
DO EITHER OF YOU HAVE A JOB
TODAY?
>> CURRENTLY, I AM EMPLOYED.
>> AND DO YOU HAVE A JOB?
>> I DO HAVE A JOB.
I AM ACTUALLY AT MEDICAL LEAVE
FOR A PROCEDURE I HAD.
>> Reporter: BOTH EXPECT THEY
WON'T HAVE A JOB FOR LONG.
BOTH DON'T TRUST THE VACCINE AND
ITS POSSIBLE SIDE EFFECTS.
BOTH HAVE REQUESTED RELIGIOUS
EXEMPTIONS.
WHAT RELIGION ARE YOU?
>> CATHOLIC.
>> CATHOLIC?
AND EVEN THOUGH THE POPE GOT
VACCINATED AND SAYS VACCINES ARE
FINE AND WE SHOULD BE GETTING
THEM, THAT DOESN'T WORK FOR YOU?
>> I FEEL HE IS A HYPOCRITE.
MY WHOLE LIFE --
>> Reporter: THIS IS -- THIS IS
GOD'S MESSENGER ON EARTH.
THIS IS -- THIS IS THE BISHOP OF
ROME.
>> HE IS.
HE WAS ELECTED TO THAT POSITION.
HOWEVER, HE'S NOT ABIDING BY THE
BIBLE.
>> Reporter: BOTH SAY THEY'D
GLADLY TEST FOR COVID ON A
WEEKLY BASIS INSTEAD OF GETTING
THE VACCINE.
THAT'S NOT ENOUGH FOR THE STATE
OF NEW YORK.
>> YOU NEED TO BE ASSURED THAT
THE PERSON TAKING CARE OF YOU IS
NOT GOING TO GIVE COVID TO YOU
OR YOUR NEWBORN.
>> Reporter: DONNA SCHMIDT WORKS
IN A NEONATAL ICU.
DO YOU WORRY ABOUT GIVING
SOMETHING, COVID OR ANYTHING
ELSE EVEN TO A CHILD THAT'S IN
YOUR CARE?
>> NO.
UM, BECAUSE WE ARE ALL REQUIRED
TO WEAR AND USE PPE.
WE'RE TRAINED PROFESSIONALS.
WE KNOW HOW TO USE IT PROPERLY.
>> Reporter: BOTH BELIEVE
COVID-19 IS REAL BUT DON'T
BELIEVE THE STATISTICS WHEN IT
COMES TO REPORTING COVID DEATHS
AND WHETHER THE VACCINE IS
EFFECTIVE.
THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
HOSPITALIZED AND DIE THAT ARE
VACCINATED IS EXTREMELY LOW,
COMPARED TO THOSE WHO ARE DYING
BY THE THOUSANDS EVERY WEEK OF
COVID-19.
>> THAT'S A MISCONCEPTION.
>> UH-HUH.
>> I HAVE SEEN THEM MYSELF.
I HAVE TALKED TO THEM, MYSELF.
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE ARE DYING
FROM COVID-19, EVERY WEEK.
>> HERE IS THE -- HERE IS THE
THING.
THERE'S SEVERAL HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE THAT WERE
PUT ON HOSPICE FIVE MONTHS
BEFORE COVID CAME.
THEY HAD BRAIN TUMORS.
THEY HAD LUNG CANCER.
THEY HAD COPD.
THEY HAD OTHER ELEMENTS,
ILLNESSES.
AND YET, ON THEIR ACTUAL-DEATH
CERTIFICATE, THEY DEEMED IT THAT
IT WAS PER COVID.
>> YOU CAN'T EVEN ACCEPT THAT
THE VACCINES WORK?
>> NO, I AM NOT CONVINCED THAT
THEY WORK YET.
>> YOU NEITHER?
>> NO, BECAUSE THERE'S SO MUCH
SUPPRESSED SCIENCE OUT THERE
GLOBALLY.
>> Reporter: BOTH WOMEN WHO GOT
COVID-19 FEEL BETRAYED.
A YEAR AGO, PEOPLE CHEERED THEM.
TODAY, THEY FEEL THEIR OPTIONS
FOR A LIVELIHOOD ARE BEING
RIPPED AWAY.
SO WHAT'S NEXT FOR YOU TWO?
>> AND THAT'S THE NUMBER ONE
THING THAT FRUSTRATES ME THE
MOST IS THAT WE WERE ALL
TOGETHER.
WE WERE ALL UNITED.
AND THEN, ALL OF THE SUDDEN,
THESE MANDATES COME OUT AND THEN
THEY ARE FEARFUL OF LOSING THEIR
JOBS.
AND THEY'RE BEING TOLD, OH, THIS
IS SAFE AND YOU'RE IN THE WRONG.
>> I BELIEVE THE FABRIC OF OUR
CIVILIZED FREE SOCIETY IS TRULY
AT A PRECIPICE.
AND WHEN I LAY MY HEAD DOWN NOT
ONLY AT NIGHT BUT AT THE END OF
MY LIFE IF I'M GIVEN A MOMENT, I
WANT TO KNOW AND I WANT MY
DESCENDANTS TO KNOW THAT I DID
EVERYTHING THAT I COULD AND THAT
I FOUGHT --
>> FOR WHAT WE BELIEVE IN.
>> -- FOR WHAT I KNOW TO BE TRUE
AND RIGHT.
AND IF THAT COSTS ME EVERYTHING,
SO BE IT.
>> Reporter: SO, LOOK.
A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE NOT GOING TO
AGREE WITH THESE -- WHAT THESE
TWO WOMEN SAID.
BUT I -- I WILL SAY I THANK THEM
FOR SPEAKING TO US.
IT IS NOT EASY TO SPEAK ABOUT
THESE THINGS.
THEY FEEL VERY DEEPLY IN WHAT
THEY BELIEVE.
ALL THAT SAID, THEY THOUGHT THEY
WERE GOING TO HAVE A LOT MORE
PEOPLE, A LOT MORE NURSES AND
HEALTH-CARE WORKERS WHO DID NOT
GET VACCINATED WHO WOULD BE ON
THEIR SIDE.
THAT COULD PRESSURE THE -- THE
GOVERNMENT OF NEW YORK TO NOT
PUT THIS MANDATE INTO EFFECT.
BUT WE SAW THOSE NUMBERS GO FROM
ABOUT 84% LAST WEEK TO OVER 92%
NOW.
IT IS CLEAR THAT IF YOU WANT
PEOPLE TO GET VACCINATED,
MANDATE IT.
>> A LOT OF PEOPLE RUSHING TO
GET THE VACCINE UNDER